[Applaudissements]
ma vie un combat de boss dans le kent
j'ai dû me relever mois
le premier rang des
majeures en france avant contre la
maltraitance neuf et l'ancien
j'ai passé mon enfance
essayer de calmer des minutes de vie et
la mort
au lieu de ça parce que j'aurais gagné
c'est un bourreau 10 de vos pairs les
grilles main et graviers et des
punitions
parfois extrêmes que l'on pourrait même
qualifiée de torture
l'aurez compris
durant ce qu'on est entre mes
adversaires sur redoutable moscou
c'est l'amour demain quand il deviendra
ma mère qui m'aura permis de surmonter
l'horreur et la douleur
elle entraîner
malchance
pour surmonter tous les combats ont
mérité les cas
le second round
un lieu au moment où la juge pour
enfants a décidé de me placer en foyer
d'éducation spécialisée en génie
car à 12 ans j'étais déjà depuis
longtemps en danger dans ma propre
famille et en construit avec l'album
cependant pas 5 j'ai pris beaucoup de
coups et elle dispose à bout en bout de
ce placement sans bleu e s ou encore
15 durant ces années de mise avec un
genou qu'il combine son travail
est toujours esclave
de ma violence que de la colère
de prendre malgré tout avoir gagné aux
points - secondes puisque c'est loin de
soyouz en guyane
et en sanskrit
dans ce nouveau monde est souvent tu es
gay
d'un
nouveau combat est arrivé à mes 18 ans
je
me sentais déjà usé sociale
c'est d'ailleurs avec deux complices
nous avons fait preuve d'une violence
sans moi car que ce soit
maintenant me tomber et ne sera le
prochain
le combat se poursuit entre les murs
d'une prison durant une benne de 10 ans
avec les entraînements
les premiers coups dans ce nouveau round
et
ils ont fait tomber mon nom ma liberté
et modernité
désormais je n'étais qu'un numéro
dernier par endroits à la route et à la
culpabilité
il ya certaines entreprises où j'aurais
préféré mourir plutôt que de repartir au
combat
mais je savais au fond de moi que
dimande un départ
j'avais lu deux points d'avancé
ils m'ont à soigner
les nombreux round d'observation
pour nos redresser et faire n'est pas
loin de battre votre seigneur se
comprend que l'on mérite à l'adversaire
et autres monnaies on peut le seul
combat qui me fait
des celui de devenir meilleur aurait
paris lausanne y avoir accès au pardon
et à la relaxation
alors qu'ils se consacrer chaque minute
et chacun des rounds suivants à me
défaire que ce n'est pas grave au fond
de moi
j'ai levé la rencontre et il ne rien
n'était décidé que ce serait la
meilleure version one émis appliqué pour
le reste émanant
y aller mieux chaque jour se resserrer
un peu sombre et à son équipe mais nous
fait parfois je sentais bien que pour ne
pas abandonner le combat j'ai d'abord
besoin le soutien de perspectives
d'exploits et surtout de beaucoup
d'hommes
lors de ce round je le sens des vaincus
j'ai décidé de faire le vide en
cas remplacer les quarante femmes
potentiel de transformer ma colère
détermination des malheurs en motivation
m'appelle un objectif de transformer
l'instant souvent le temps est devenue
mairesse enfants
s'en prend
donc d'opportunité je me suis tendu je
me suis saisi de la reprise les équipes
et pour la première fois demain
mon choix conséquence positive
puisque finirait par être sanctionnée de
divers
les moments de répit entre sacro ont
permis une petite boutique de me
concentrer et de réfléchir à la manière
de mener 9
/ commencé effet pas qu'il y ait de
nouveaux choix pendant que jamais
appliquées par les abeilles que
l'essentiel
n'est pas empêché beaucoup de sauts
c'est vrai mais c'était sans compter sur
les nombreux cercle vertueux de l'oeuvre
des armes et que j'allais trouver au
fond de moi un véritable trésor
le pouvoir d'agir dans lequel chaque
seconde de ma vie par de nouvelles
décisions de nouveau projet de loi crée
mai prochain
oui j'ai évolué parce que
je les ai compris lorsque j'ai vu
espérer qu'il ya la partie du lot de la
même manière qu espéré grimal madère et
remind
alors plutôt que de nourrir un sentiment
de vengeance et de lustres et jouera
plusieurs mâles violence
j'ai décidé
d'élever une shakira depuis son seuil de
tolérance et de fer agrément même sunday
news
de cette nouvelle production une
philosophie est née entre les murs de
lignes de ma peine
je devais faire l'union aurait par
ailleurs
donné le meilleur de moi-même pour
gagner le combat de ma vie
alors même si j'étais seul sur ce ring
et que ce combat est fermée on ne s'en
sort jamais vraiment seul
dans mon coin surmontable de nombreuses
forces mentaux il y avait mon coach
mais soigner ce qui est boxeur qui
s'entraînait depuis déjà très longtemps
et qui m'a
transmis
son extérieur
on m'a appris à mieux gérer le temps
entre chaque étape du combat à faire la
différence en deux minutes est la
suivante
cet aumônier qui n'étaient pas d'accord
sauvez mon âme mais plutôt comme aider à
ne pas raccrocher l'on vient le voir
autrement que seulement un combattant il
m'a convaincu oui j'ai possédé en menant
à leur sens nécessaire pour surmonter à
la fois mon père
mais aussi un
mais épreuve et puis il ya eu le regard
de tous ces professionnels qui ont cru
en main tutoie les modèles nulle envie
d'y croire ici et tant d'autres encore
tous ont contribué à le relever il a
transformé ce combat
on a un noble art de vivre
depuis toujours j'avais
et grandir pour reconduire de
l'enfermement ma solitude pour vivre
ensemble reprenons
il est de nos jours j'ai réalisé que moi
aussi j'avais le droit au pardon bien
que pour moi aussi et les habitats
marins un bout de peau nue dans le coeur
de ceux qui comptent pas
alors si naturellement
aujourd'hui russe de mes blessures
profondes je lui ai dit numéro 116
points de ligne de lapins de ceux qui
vivent le même combat que celui gagné il
ya vingt ans d engager boxe avec les
mains on s'aimerait à leurs côtés c'est
ma façon de me protéger
ce combat n'est fini les dernièrement
mon coach nous devenus monotones
les soigneurs sont nos enfants ils sont
à force ma chance magnifique
alors c'est vrai que la vie
peut-être dur parfois comporté dégoûté
mais en même temps elle est ce que nous
avons de plus précieux
alors il ne s'agit pas d'encaisser des
coups de la ville
on descend rappelle que l'espérance ont
dit non mais plutôt de regarder des
épreuves comme des opportunités et des
chances de se relever toujours plus fort
après chaque chute
un
challenger aventure il n'avait qu'un
paquebot des affaires
qui m'aura permis de reprendre mais
robert et de décocher le plus beau coup
de poing
alors soit aussi les épreuves font
tomber
un concert relais froid et matois pour
devenir le champion toute catégorie de
taille
jose
[Applaudissements]